he is big Cheeto oh three Greedo the
emotion of the city is what they call me
you feel me right here with bootleg kids
boo like that podcast special guest
finally we got him
fresh off of a incredible
Novo run here in Los Angeles yeah your
welcome home shows I heard where
legendary
yeah it was turned to [__] up oh three
Greedo man you could cause on it you can
say whatever you want man
um um welcome home man appreciate you
it's good to see you uh you know I mean
I feel like while you've been
incarcerated I brought your name up so
much in so many interviews because I
feel like you don't get enough respect
when it comes to just your influence
you know I feel like you and Draco had
that in common in terms of just like
just the influence on like a whole
entire generation of
what we what we consider hip-hop you
know what I'm saying just whether it's
LA or not man so it's good to see you
man welcome
hell yeah we just on some updating like
let's
we understand what the original culture
was and it still is to some people of
those ages or wherever they from but we
like bro we got Detroit Partners in
Atlanta partners and New York Partners
and Memphis Partners like it's really
like the whole world is on their fashion
now it's not like when like you had to
look at certain states that have Big T's
and fire station where the khakis like
everybody's wearing Balenciaga and
they've been doing that in La we want to
speak for that we want to speak for the
flockers we want to speak for like the
other pieces of the culture from here
whether we was doing it or not was not
what we were trying to put we were just
putting a soundtrack to people who had
to do that to get how they live the
flockers the Trappers just the whole
line just it was just all three of us I
was gonna say Shoreline too yeah
Shoreline had a lot a lot of influence
as well so I got to give them props
because I feel like it was kind of at
the same time y'all all kind of getting
it yeah that was our family drummer
seeing Mafia drummers kinky beaches that
was our family Draco Carl just said
um
yeah that's how it was though and we was
all just on something like this the new
wave even though Jeezy like [__] oh
Jeezy showed a new culture I feel like
for
Hispanics from Los Angeles even though
there is a lot of new artists that are
suspending this R2 I'm just saying at
the time
people didn't know like there was people
that was living like he was living or
dressing like that's why I tell oh Jeezy
I'm like you kind of because I'm from
Arizona so I'm very well aware of like
Chicano rap and a lot like a lot of the
Mexican rap history I'm like oh geezy
you kind of show people like you don't
have to make that like stereotypical not
even just that that was like really who
he was like for sure uh he was really
like we didn't dress him in what he was
dressed in you know I'm saying he was
coming with them CDG Air Forces and [__]
right spilling lean all over them or
just the way that he was doing [__] was
like damn this [__] is hella creative
so I really
um took it like an old Jeezy early
do you remember how old you were or how
old Jeezy was when you guys initially
met because oh no he was a baby all them
[__] babies I'm the big bro you know
right you're the big homie yeah all them
[__] babies y'all talking to someone
the other day and he told me how old he
was turning I don't know if he told
anybody yeah I'm like never what the
[__] like you're only that old my little
kid you know what I'm saying so I'm like
oh [__] but um I had personal time with
every member of uh
Shoreline I can't say every member's
thinking because it's a million but a
lot of uh
me and Ralphie probably have more songs
from back then than me and Draco doing
we got a lot of songs shout out to
Ralphie who's just up here even with
catchy the great like that was one of my
co-stars and he was stink team so
um
that was just a fun ass time it was
heartbreaking so much stuff that came
behind it
because it was like our [__] broke up
when we didn't even break up you know
what I'm saying it was just like you go
you go away you gotta go sit down
obviously Shoreline kind of goes their
separate ways you know rest in peace to
Draco rest in peace to catchy it just
like you said Long Live you know what
I'm saying we right we we going on
whatever we ain't we ain't getting no
Rest Long Live I was gonna say for you
you you're being locked you're being
locked up when Draco passes that had to
be a hard thing to deal with from you
know Behind Bars yeah I ain't really
rock with the phone for a while after
that you know what I'm saying I didn't
really
just knowing my background and the type
of individuals I come up around like I
know that nobody got no filter and I
didn't really want to hear it uh
no opinions or anything more than what I
was already hearing because the stories
were sounding crazy
and
just wrapping my
mind around everything because I had
just
lost off I think that was just a few
weeks before yeah dog passed away in
November uh and then Draco passed away
in December and it's different when it's
people that you know spend time with or
shook hands with her
Vibe with or anything you know what I'm
saying or
oh yeah Dolph was a close friend of my
Dolph was a great guy the last
what I woke up in a mansion where I was
with a lil pump and Uzi and
smoke purp and dub and we was in there
and we was recording and chilling and
[__] and I missed my flight to go to
Texas so I caught the first one in the
morning and then the last people that I
talked to on the phone
was nipsy and Dolph or getting on the
plane before you turn yourself in yeah
so it was just like crazy you know like
uh the people that were
rooting for me or you know whatever uh
collaborate with me or whatever the case
is whatever our relationship was it was
just crazy to
just somebody that you used to just
shake hands with okay out of all the
bunch this is what's going on and then
they started to feel like back to back
with pnb
Rocky yeah and let alone like homies
from my ghetto or like we don't know
there was just so many
things back to back our childhood
friends
or just family members off code so I was
just like you know when the Draco [__]
came it was towards the end
as well as the takeoff and pnb rock and
it was just like you know I'm just
moving my phone away man
um yeah you know what I'm saying just
if it wasn't taking care of business I
wasn't really getting on the phone right
I can't blame you man
what was uh the the conversation with
nip and Dolph like before you turn
yourself in
nip first thing was just like um
don't worry about it
because even though you gonna be gone
you left such an impact on the city
it's gonna go it's gonna keep going
everybody love you Greedo like you know
what I'm saying I'm calling you as a
brother you know what I'm saying just
you know giving me that pep talk before
I went out to the ring you know what I'm
saying just that always was you know the
coach you know what I'm saying that
always was
I mean we did a few songs we did some
songs but our relationship was just kind
of like just
Oh no just like yeah [__] like he was
so excited for me he would call me when
I go to New York for the first time or
go to double XL or wherever I'm going
and he'd just be like yeah [__] yeah I
just this is just this is this yeah this
is what you're supposed to be doing and
just like I'll be telling people like
when I saw Kobe's funeral and Jordan was
talking about when Kobe hit him any time
of the night hey should I shoot like
this should I do like that that's who
Nipsey was for me like most rappers we
operate like in the wee hours of the
night anyway but
um just at pep talk and the same with
dogs just the same old
you know what I'm saying you good you're
gonna bounce back
Dolph was a great guy man nipsy of
course I mean it's just it's just I feel
like it's crazy to think like Leo's man
because you got locked up was it 2018
yeah and just to think like how the like
all the people got locked up I turned
myself in that was crucial and I had to
turn myself in on a plane run what the
[__] that's crazy oh I didn't want to go
I already missed the flight
and I'm sitting here in this mansion
with Uzi and all these [__] I'm like
man I'm a rap all right come on no
you're right we're pumping okay Catch Me
If You Can I'd have did it before [__]
this but I was like man let me take care
of this because if it turns out worse
you won't be talking to me today you
know what I'm saying I won't be selling
out the novo two nights in a row and
going on the road you know what I'm
saying that my PO said okay because it's
looking like something
well you were prepared for you know
because you were supposed like like your
sentence originally we you were supposed
to be gone for about 10 years right
twenty twenty still got 20 years right
now bro I'm on parole but they Pro is
like you still got to do the rest of
your time
so I get off parole in 2038 so period
but you're free you're able to cut yeah
just be on on your p's and q's I was
gonna say like I remember talking to TK
about just the amount of music that was
just I got that from Lil Wayne when he
was finna go to jail right I got that
for sure from Lil Wayne because you were
I had heard stories that you were doing
the records and then shooting like back
to back to back to back music videos
yeah it's still hella unreleased videos
I have released a video to substance way
later and then it took off on Tick Tock
I I uh paid whoever was in charge of
that I guess I was doing so much at the
time they never paid the director and
then when I when I found out I shot him
the bread and then we released it
and then Tick Tock took it
tick tock wasn't a thing when you when
you was out early yeah thank you there's
this thing where you just swipe it it
just shows you everything you like
you I saw at one point the substance
challenge was like them showing their
teeth yeah like
if this is what's bringing the Platinum
black shouting [__] I'm with it
[__] whatever the challenge is do
that [__] I love it do you remember or
have an idea of the amount of records
that you cut in case you did have to
well already I ain't gonna lie to you I
already recorded like
hella songs every day of my life look
any chance that I got even when I lived
in the trap in the uh Power Hood in the
Campanella Park
well I'm just recording recording your
phone down there
[Music]
okay recording recording recording you
know what I'm saying it's like
I always wanted to be like Lil Wayne or
like at the time like it was some Gucci
[__] going crazy right Jeezy in the
Gucci gangster girls just blew my mind
just at the time we were so into it it
was like watching wrestling or something
goddamn like we was with into every
character we're like what's drama doing
with Gucci Mane that he all on the
background
um talking about the Gucci has been
inducted abducted we like oh [__] and at
the time I didn't even I wasn't
the hugest Gucci fan but I had just got
out of jail my cousin played me that
[__]
and it was just like this [__] didn't
evolved into a superhuman this is around
the time when photos shooting I'm a star
came out this way Gucci the movie and
burping 3D came out with DJ Drama and I
was just like
what the [__] like I want to have my
fans indulge like that that's why it was
so important to hurry up and drop when I
came home before I dropped like a real
tape that was just the [__] we could
clear
I mean it's crazy too because your
output is at such a high level like I
think Gucci's album that he dropped
either earlier this year or late last
year I had like 70 songs you just
dropped the 33 song project you know
what I'm saying like Gucci can't be
[__] with the Gucci future
Lil Wayne
and I'll say Boosie that's like my
mixtape Mount Rushmore that's like if
you really pay attention that's really
what all my [__] is and then when I
heard Thug later on
that's what kind of like helped me play
with my voice more and [__] like really
being a big fan of them yeah Thug did a
good job of I always say using his voice
is like an instrument kinda yeah cause
I've been on that but I just was like
kind of like not going all the way
full players like pop star with it
because of where I was from and who I
was around because it sounded like
substance yeah it's like I slip like the
gangster lyrics in it but the whole
setup of that song is like this [__]
really like not even some of you would
think a black [__] would make you know
what I'm saying
and that's why that [__] is so Timeless
and [__] like that yeah you uh you pride
yourself on not necessarily I saw you
correct somebody
in terms of like not making quote
unquote West Coast rap
that's a genre stop a record store
sometimes you'll see West Coast rap 100
that's a genre I'm saying I'm not the
genre that was like some characters
for that time we all characters so I'm
not saying that to take nothing from him
but those people were from places that
aren't even close to where I'm from you
know what I'm saying they're not even
from the state that I'm from but a lot
of them not even just like at the end of
the day I'm telling the story of
you know going up Wilmington to going
down Rosecrans I'm going from Wise
Compton and Gardena like the regions
that I really know you know I'm painting
that picture you know what I'm saying so
I just
try to show people like you know the
reason I don't jump on that is because
I'm a real trap [__] too right you know
what I'm saying I'm a real out of town
[__] too I'm a real you know what I'm
saying I still be with my peoples from
other states you know what I'm saying
well you described your last day before
turning yourself in as to me a perfect
example of what you were able to help do
and that was Bridge
a whole world of like you mentioned pump
and Uzi right and shout out to Desto dub
who actually helped a lot of this too
but just there's like a whole generation
of kids that were looking for like a an
artist like yourself like Draco like
Shoreline to kind of like not
necessarily you know like you said be
honest it's like it's like six or seven
artists that's out right now I won't I
won't just say their name in case it
makes it I want to make it seem like
it's a flex on right but they'll give me
my you know respect on that [__] of me
like opening up
a door where where artists could be
different or you could be more melodic
but you could talk about what you want
to talk about
or like even like the producer there's a
lot of people that make their own beef
Stewarts people that just only make
beats uh Inspire producers just like
producing never been or you know what
I'm saying just like some of my bigger
songs sweet lady you know what I'm
saying or people
you know what I'm saying just seeing
like those are real people in the songs
and [__] I just let people say you know
tell your own story you know I'm saying
be yourself if you like whatever you
like you know what I'm saying
um while you're locked up versus pops
off
and I've been saying this you and RJ did
the first verses ever
yeah I remember the individual I did it
with I remember I had thought of that
idea
and it was jumping I remember me and DJ
head were like uh I feel like that's
always a touchy situation I don't wanna
answer none to make it feel like
we restarting on disrespect no no I'm
not even talking about that specific
situation I'm just saying like it's just
kind of crazy to think like so I'll just
try to stay talking about me that was
the situation that was a very successful
peaceful event that you know we always
meet me and had always talk we're like
but that Loki was the first verses that
ever happened like you know what I'm
saying like yeah but I missed out I mean
I didn't do any paperwork because that
was the no yeah I created that Novo and
you guys did it in Orange County right
yeah yeah I didn't do no paperwork to
say that I created that and then um
um I was telling uh Picasso like hey man
I probably should trademark this because
ain't nobody never did this he was like
well it kind of with Drake versus Lil
Wayne I guess he had a tour yeah where
they said it like that I'm like but they
from the same team I'm saying this is
like something that could even turn into
violence and I and I um
I will probably just rather get the
credit for doing something positive it
was something they're just saying that I
was the first to create that because I
didn't I didn't I mean
yeah
the concept is similar but
no but it was it was dope to see that
positive outcome of that because you
know what ended up happening but I just
thought I just thought it was though
like again you're an innovator man so I
wish I did do some paperwork on how to
make some money for sure I did not
missed out on that how crazy was it
dealing with kovi while being
incarcerated having coveted while
incarcerated was horrible and then I
feel like I still don't believe the same
and [__] so you had it could you taste
could you smell yeah I'm greedy I'm
gonna still taste that food I got to eat
but
my body was feeling like I got hit with
like some
some heaviest [__] like I got into an
accident or something like God damn so
hit you and I was wondering the covet
doubt is like that's not no real [__]
and then you got y'all out there going
through weird [__] yeah they're telling
me it's like a ghost and I'm like that's
what y'all get I'm out here in a ghost
town yeah everybody was kind of in their
especially La I'm sure you heard La was
crazy there was no traffic which is like
you could get to wherever you wanted
actually
I don't know make I don't know bro there
was Zero traffic you could get to like
Orange County in like 20 minutes I mean
if I'd have been flying in that ass it
was crazy bro like and then the homeless
shape just blew up like I don't know if
I mean there was always homeless [__]
you know obviously but now it's like
wherever you're at oh yeah it's them
encampments it's turning up in La man
it's oh yeah you'd be in a nice area
sometimes yeah like Venice Beach during
the pandemic
I'll never be in L.A like that no more
it's just
I like experience in life you know what
I'm saying I like to see new things
I didn't did LA of course I understand
what comes with being like
one of the first people living this life
from you know any of the areas I came up
in yeah
so I walk late I don't really come to
L.A I know where I'm at I know what I'm
what it's about it's also like why put
yourself in the way if you don't gotta
be it's like anything you that you could
do as a rapper you've seen and done like
you only got to do the necessary [__]
you know that's right that's I think
that's what people like unfortunately
like you know
when we hear about stuff happening to
artists when they come to La it's like
but you were probably moving around you
know a little irresistible where you was
at you should have just been in your BMV
you're like why are you going away with
Melrose
you know what I mean like yeah yeah so
you know it is this ain't no place where
they gonna fake like they respect a
certain person a certain type of person
people do anything oh yeah
um speak to the correlation because you
and Draco were and uh and even the you
know oh Jeezy and those guys heavily
tied in with the Detroit guys early too
I think I want to say like some of the
earliest pz I ever heard was through
y'all so like give me the what is it
about Detroit
and the West Coast that it it they feel
like Country Cousins you know what I'm
saying like I don't know about the West
Coast I know about like well I don't see
the bay and then like you guys I know I
know where I'm from it's just like you
know similar mentality similar like
dress code similar
kind of not accents because it's
different but
it's almost like similar similar a lot
of people kind of get the younger
artists get their flow
like being influenced by Detroit artists
um I'm doing a hotel with hell of a
great production and I said a lot of it
sounds like you know that old Mob music
like before they did the hypey [__] like
that oh E40 [__] and [__] and he's like
yeah [__] I used to jam nothing but
that
so it's just like you know it's always
been certain places that [__] with uh
California too because even when I was
in Texas Houston always be like yeah
we've been [__] with y'all like we
[__] with y'all heavy right just on
the street level so I don't know oh no I
guess we just talk with each other we
like how each other right uh out of all
those songs you recorded before you went
in or you just like are we still putting
those out or now that you're out are you
trying to like
like I'll touch up the stuff I have with
like some of the peoples in the past
just to make sure it's it's right right
right but um
some of that [__] ain't never gonna come
out I don't know give it to my daughter
or something let her flip that [__] or
something when I'm old I love that
what's up y'all we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good friends at my bookie that's
right it is NBA Finals you gotta Hammer
the Nuggets I don't know they might
sweep the the heat I would look at the
like serious odds on that go to my
bookie right now let's get some money
man all right baseball of course is in
full effect we got Stanley Cup finals
NFL seasons on the way sign up at
mybookie.ag right now use the promo code
bootleg and you will get that first
deposit bonus
all right look I don't care where you're
at you can go to mybookie.ag Let's
gamble on some sports they got the
casino you can do live Blackjack you can
do live roulette craps you could do all
kinds of slots and of course bet on the
NBA Finals bet on the NHL uh Stanley Cup
finals crazy shots of the Vegas golden
knights that's what I'm rooting for and
of course baseball season man all right
so look right now mybookie.ag use that
promo code bootleg uh and sign up when
you do use uh that promo code they're
going to give you a first deposit bonus
straight to your account free money all
right mybookie.ag go do that also gotta
give a shout out to our family at Blue
chew that's right ladies and gentlemen
it's getting hot outside that means
I don't know what that means it's just
hot so I feel like when it's hot people
want to [__] more right so you know
fellas if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction it happens to the best of us
I'm sure maybe you are old maybe you are
dealing with stress at work maybe you
don't want to sleep with the same lady
that you're married to over and over
need a little extra motivation to get
that thing stayed up you know what I
mean go to uhboochu.com use the promo
code bootleg and they'll send it
straight to your door three-month supply
of Bluetooth for free all right now does
Bluetooth work yes it does you're gonna
get a free month supply to be able to
see for yourself blue shoe.com promo
code bootleg uh now if you don't know
what it is it is the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form and you do not have to go
to a doctor's appointment all right you
do everything online you don't have to
go sit at a doctor's office and talk to
some old man in a lab coat about your
dick issues not necessary anymore in
2023 all right so go to Bluetooth sign
up with that promo code bootleg get a
month supply for free let's get back to
the interviews has anyone approached you
about buying your catalog yet because
you know everyone's buying catalogs no I
I like that though I like that well
right now I'm probably not the same time
next year but right now I'm like I'm if
you know you know type artist you know
what I'm saying so but you have a lot of
Independence ain't nobody coming at me
with that [__] man
I mean I got a reputation for my
reactions um
I'm a real artist like I take this to
Heart like
I was just talking to Deb about some the
way I was looking at something just
creatively people don't know how much I
put into like my album covers or my
videos myself like
even like some of the videos they
dropped since I've been out I had to
cuss everybody out like I need to start
directing my own [__] because it's like
y'all hear the lyrics how y'all hear it
and interpret how y'all do but that's
not even telling the story of the song
You Feel Me
so oh no I'll just be big on
representing who I am as ours like
standing up for this [__] like
really like I got this tree story and
this street respect or whatever but
I'm still like a for real kid a Kanye
kid a Virgil kid you know what I'm
saying so
I'm trying to leave a stamp like I'm
trying to stay in the world with like a
cold
Trail you know what I'm saying something
that ain't just normal you know what I'm
saying yeah and I think like uh if you
think I mean I always say this like if
you think about the guys who are
I call them like forever guys like
there's a certain amount of attention to
detail all those guys have you know
whether it's Drake whether it's cold
whether it's Kendrick like the attention
to detail to every little thing is like
very high you know what I'm saying like
and they're also very heavily influenced
I think with like you said the artwork
a lot of guys will just drop a just pay
some dude online
people got to realize like ain't nothing
more forever than music or a moment that
involves music like that's why you
remember certain moments you know what
I'm saying
certain like songs might sample some
from your past and you'll remember
exactly what you was doing at that time
you feel me what's your earliest hip-hop
memory
in the future in your friend when my
uncle had like a pull out radio and I'm
so lame I'm like let me hold that
[__] I just want to hold it yeah
man like I got this big ass radio but
just uh hearing ain't no future in your
friend like that beat over and over I
was like what oh
so that [__] was just like what the [__]
is this yeah I used to be in love with
that little sound it's in that dope man
dope medicine that [__] too you know
that little sound I love did your uh
Uncle have a CD book with some heat in
it or was it a tape deck or what was it
oh both I've seen both of them levels oh
great he's always had like the older
cousin who had like the fat CD book that
I couldn't afford to have yeah yeah that
used to be the thing especially [__]
that had like Tahoes and [__] back in
the day oh yeah that CD book you had a
seven disc changer and you'd be in that
[__] hold on guys okay that used to be
the [__] in California like a two-door
Tower or something oh man beat it out
nothing like it would get stolen too
yeah that goes on or they just take
something out of it you got you got
certain albums behind certain albums and
[__] like I got that you on some old
[__] [__] that wasn't me though that
was like some older [__] I was with
but um
you know I'm definitely yeah I mean on
this I'm 30. and you know what was hard
about CDs you know it was hard how uh
Outcast or Rick Ross like always every
disc well Outcast all the discs were
naked women naked [__] yeah with like
colors and [__] and then Rick Ross had a
different color of him with the beer
yeah every that's I think that's one
thing that we're missing like I mean
obviously you can still go buy vinyls
and stuff but like just the like like
you said attention to detail like
outcasts they always had some fly [__]
on their discs like yeah I wish I could
have been in that area to make some some
crazy ass like some sort of theme
whatever like sometimes you or you might
put them all together and it shows like
yeah for sure no I still think about
like okay like I just think about Snoop
Dogg's doggy style that blue picture of
snoop's head yeah yeah shout out to
Snoop man I ain't gonna lie rap used to
be more serious like as far as like how
to get it it's easier to get it so it's
smooth now for my money on great but I
remember like going to certain barber
shops and going to the record store next
door and getting like them free shits in
the dough and it'd be like a sampler
it'd be like sniffing yeah
or you go to the store and they'd have
like uh
there's this virgin mega store by my
house and uh you could go and put on the
headphones and like listen to CDs in the
store oh yeah I do that and then I play
the [__] but I was gonna be skipping
like you remember the video game samples
at the like you'll be able to go to
GameStop and play a game before it came
out yeah that [__] was lit yeah yeah all
that [__] used to be the reason you was
in there been hanging out in there just
playing 2K all day they'd be like you
gotta go you gotta buy something yeah
yeah [__] uh are you a Laker fan
well you're a basketball guy we were
just talking Sports so are you what's
your team I like all the players on the
Lakers so are you a Laker fan
Liz Liz
how my [__] from the bottom so anybody
who from out here that know like about
being in like certain programs as a kid
because you have bad behavior or
whatever you was on the field trip you
going to a Clippers game on the flow
you're going like you damn it on the
floor back there everybody I'm gonna go
on the floor the Clippers game yeah for
the low so I just grew up with Clipper
fans just being a poor [__] and [__]
but wait wait wait wait
we have a Clippers fan here this is very
rare well great but I [__] with
everybody that's on the Lakers this is
amazing I respect the Lakers story I
respect you for being a Clippers fan I
love that [__] we always get a good team
we ain't gonna never win it so I'm gonna
be just like oh man we're gonna win like
I got I pay attention to everybody and
[__] I respect anybody who because I'm a
die hard Clipper fan I'm a Suns fan and
I'm a Arizona Cardinals Fan so I'm a
tortured sports fan I don't know what
it's like to have a championship but
you're I mean a Clipper what they always
almost do some [__] almost
and to me I'd rather be the Clippers and
like never even sniff it because then I
could be like hell no at this point I
know it ain't gonna happen but I just
love them anyway [__] yeah I mean I
just had Baron Davis here we were kind
of going over some of like those OG
Clipper teams that like even the ones he
was on and then like there was the year
that Sam Cassell Tim Thomas was on the
team Darius miles Cory mcgetty Quinn
Richardson cute rich Michael Oliver
candy oh come on man it was some heat
over there just Michael candy the
biggest bust ever maybe sheesh he might
be one of them right oh no these [__]
might want to do some Partnerships or
something they ran into anything I don't
know [__] hey I'm rocking with all of
them but
I don't know maybe I need to run my my
bees up and go get involved and get some
Clipper [__] going you can probably be
part owner
listen they could use you as the
halftime Talent let me tell you
something that shouldn't be packed out
I've been to like 12 Clipper games
because again I get to go watch my sons
and then we have eliminated y'all two or
three years in a row yeah definitely but
every halftime show
it's like k-day [__] halftime it's
like too short I think baby batteries
before it's like the old school hip-hop
halftime show every time Kid Ink was
there yeah they got they need Greedo to
touch that stage man you got to touch
that stuff
hey who's the greatest Clipper of all
time is it Chris Paul
no no disrespected Chris probably hell
no who is it because he wasn't even
really like no OG clipper
Danny Manning I don't know like who the
best Clipper Blake
[Music]
Blake at that time was a beast
um Darius miles at that time was a beast
Queen Richmond was a beast Lamar
nah
It's gotta hey who's my favorite I don't
know who's the best Clipper because
who's your favorite all-time Patrick
Beverly all right yeah that [__] be
pissed I like him every team he going
because he just
I don't know like I like that like he
don't care he go he gonna be himself he
ready to start fighting everything he
just I don't know it reminds me of like
Patrick Beverly has some of the crazy he
just have you seen his podcast
so recently he said that I don't know
you saw how you meant when they traded
him to the Timberwolves and then the
Timberwolves beat the Clippers and the
Olympics on my weak ass Clippers and
he's standing on a thing he just said
like a week ago he said well we did in
Minnesota that one year in that playing
game means more than what hey but he
opened up his offensive game in
Minnesota though I ain't gonna lie he
was going off in the playoffs in the
playoffs was that last year when it was
uh they traded uh John's dad got the
[__] where the jersey that was last
year
Patrick Beverly was definitely shooting
threes and [__] he even turnt up at the
boys a little bit he just ain't gonna be
you know well I don't know what he gonna
be I wish he could be because that's one
of my favorite players I like I like
players like that they don't you know
what I'm saying we ain't doing the norm
like we going against the grain no I
love Patrick Beverly he's like the kind
of guy who you hate until he's on your
team and then you love him hell yeah nah
for real I know I I respected anytime I
see my boy I'm like yeah he's like
because like I I hate Draymond Green
like I love like I've met him he's a
nice guy but as a player I [__] hate
dreaming yeah don't let Draymond Green
come on the sons
I don't think I got no player I just
hate that girl I wouldn't say hates a
bad word Sports I call it Sports hate no
no I'm thinking like who I just sports
day probably in football or something
like I Sports hate Steph Curry
trippy I Just Sports hate him dude I'm
just like he's too perfect he's too
perfect I want some Scandal can he slide
into it he probably got some Scandal but
you know they'd be sweeping under the
rough for the big dog it's hard to sweep
it under the rug these days you see Zion
out here with these he's he's a [__]
wow oh no see you trying to go I ain't
always trying to design a man
hey
whatever we go through with these
females I I feel
hey say man listen we I don't I'm not 28
2018 you go in you get out only fans is
a thing so there's just way more chicks
that are like fully engaged just period
and like people on some other [__]
Females Be not all of them it's gotten a
lot worse maybe on some other [__] they
don't really ask for something like who
the [__] you talking about it's the only
fans generation man it's that it's the
getting flown out generation when you
see a girl and she has more than one
city in her bio
no I'll be watching just what's going on
like I'll be I might meet a female and
then know where the situation is and
then I'll see him I can [__] him
Bali and Dubai and [__] I'm like what
you doing out there how'd you get there
yeah if I scroll up on our text messages
it don't look like you can but anyways
yeah no for sure
um tell me about obviously uh you got a
ton of music what are you currently
working on is there like give me kind of
the rundown what we're gonna expect from
Greedo the rest of the year
I don't know when that should be coming
out I got wolf of Gray Street too uh
Gray Street Journal coming out it's
really a collab type low-key it's gonna
make it like a stamp a legendary stamp
crazy features on there
um it was on on the tape oh I can't tell
you that it was hot this is it's quite
the list though it's on there can I
guess
you probably ain't gonna guess right
how big are we going
see what I'm saying now you want me to
help you get a little Drake Drake on
there
do you love me uh that's inspired by
sweet lady so I got credits on that
album for that you do I didn't know that
yeah if you type in
Greedo Drake sweet lady or something is
gonna pop up like that yeah he gives a
list of all his Inspirations off that
album though oh that's dope Drake [__]
with the team you know what I'm saying
but I think him and Draco got a record
out yeah I don't know
um I'm just not really coming out of my
little cave I have noticed I've noticed
because I was dming you when you were
and then uh TK and he's like yo he's in
a halfway house if you were to interview
him you have to go to Texas I was like I
mean I'm down but you know it's it's you
you've definitely it's dope to see you
out moving around
and and I think your personality is so
fire that I think like it's just good to
see you you know talking and and you
know kind of spreading spreading uh who
you are a lot more
oh no the city be letting me know how
they look at me I just like that [__]
yeah they don't put me on no
they put me chopped here for sure so I
just I just [__] without trying to show
as much love back you know what I'm
saying everybody that
kind of kept this [__] going while I was
going
uh you and uh you said you and Ralphie
got a ton of unreleased stuff would you
guys do a
whole project
eventually but
before we do just hurry up and do a tape
like that's probably most likely what I
would have to do with Uzi like
how we gonna pick it should be an album
or so much [__] how many uh unreleased
songs with Uzi do you got see there you
go a lot there you go because once they
hit a certain number of leaks they can
blow yeah that's all of them ten twenty
we're good yeah enough to do a project
no we got more than that we kind of
probably scrapped the old [__] so
whatever engineer has that probably is
it
Uzi seems to be like one of the nicer
like more genuine dudes in music they
want a good friend you guys have uh have
you guys gotten back in since you've
gotten out
yo that is a memeable
expression right there
that has a yes
look at this guy's face
oh no are you on the pink tape
no I'm not on the pink tape I wear
purple
I mean it could be the purple tape for
one track you know now we got something
going but I don't know but I don't know
what I can tell you what I can't but
who's he gonna always be involved how
did you guys initially uh link up
oh my DM them when um what you want what
you really want what do you want I'm not
your [__] how are we [__] with you in
the Jordan Downs and I guess like a year
and a half or two years later he was
gonna DM me
and it was just me like Lincoln whenever
like we [__] with you
like and the crazy [__] is is you
talking to me like I don't know who you
is and then we just start chopping it up
and linked up that's fire gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our family
at Odd Socks that's right the most
comfortable socks in the world ladies
and gentlemen uh go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg Kev or bootleg both promo codes
work you'll save 20 out at checkout uh
20 off these are the Odd Socks Basics
all right now you can get like a pack of
all black pack of all whites of course
they got all kind of crazy licenses WWE
Cheech and Chong they got Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles they got SpongeBob
SquarePants bruh look they got the
SpongeBob SquarePants Krabby Patty
draws
yeah now you don't want crabs but you do
want Mr crab's underwear because these
are fire all right so look go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code uh bootleg save 20 off the
checkout and uh yeah listen trust me
when I say most comfortable socks you'll
ever put on your [__] feet
and the most comfortable boxer briefs
what are we talking about man all right
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off of checkout great gift and
and just treat yourself all right uh
also
got a shout out to our family a King
Palm now if you guys don't know about
King pong kingpong is all natural baby
yes all right we're talking about the
leader when it comes to uh tobacco-free
natural organic Leaf wraps if you're a
smoker a toader a straight west coaster
you know what I'm saying whatever you're
into King Palms they got it for you
what's great about
um these these are like one of the best
uh products that they sell now this is a
terpene infused tobacco-free leaf
and what's dope is you stuff your flour
into it
and then you press on the thingy you
know what I'm saying
and then you got flavor I'm going to
show you what it looks like when it's
stuffed
with some great tree from Jardin of
course
ah look at that
right get that thing stuffed up
the tip has got that flavor in it uh
wherever you're at man make sure you
check out the uh
um you know they got the smoke shops
they got those on lock they got
7-Elevens on lock we only smoking out of
King Palms baby you already know what it
is and if you go to
kingpoms.com
kingpom.com kingpom.com
and you use the promo code bootleg Kev
you will save 50 off at checkout
half off at checkout 50 off if you go to
kingpom.com and use that promo code the
promo code is down below go run it up
try some of these flavors too man the
peach pineapple the Strawberry Shortcake
they just got so much going on there's
also all kind of dope smoking
accessories you can get half off y'all
what are we talking about save 50 off
kingpom.com promo code below it's either
bootleg or bootleg have them these promo
codes got my head hurt try both of them
all right one of them get you 50 off God
damn it anyway let's get back to the
interview how dope is it to see
the
just staple that Desto dub has become in
fashion
hey I was up in that [__] Factory and
that [__] just made me so happy because
I've already seen him hella ton like me
and Doug always together on accident we
just we both upgraded so we both living
like them diamonds like oh yeah I meet
him at the pinky out type spots you feel
me now so I was like oh okay
but uh when I actually saw his Warehouse
I was just like but you're doing it for
real
bro they don't know you know what I'm
saying we were just talking about that
[__] earlier like this is greedy and
double low they don't know
like we've been rocking so it's just
like what the [__] is this going on in
here wait no he's got the whole no
jumper space on Melrose like it's crazy
I'm like what are you doing what is that
man but no that's bro we talk every day
and [__] they gotta uh let I think I
think I saw like LAUSD like banned a
whole lot of from being in schools oh no
shout out to them shout out to LAUSD for
sure no it's just dope to see like we
ain't messing up nothing his his uh his
his grind is paid off and it's just from
the van getting the band bipped a bunch
of times
to you know doing collabs with everybody
like it's kind of crazy man for sure
um and he jam-packed like the day after
my show he had the uh
oh the collabs park right after I'm like
this [__]
you know what I'm saying you be in such
a high fashion guy would you ever do uh
I mean the merch is fire you just thank
you for the hoodies you brought me but
um would you ever do a clothing line
[Applause]
[Music]
who told you to ask all these questions
nobody he's jumping you tapped in or
something no no I've gotten zero
information I swear okay stay tuned I
promise bro I promise I would tell you
if like
no this was looking he's like where's TK
nah I promise no no you're good man huh
are you uh so kind of give me um
we talked about
the Clippers a little there's been word
that they might break up the Gang
they might trade Paul George Lancaster's
finest Palmdale and they gonna trade
every good they do that if you don't
know what we do over here at the
Clippers
besides B we get a squad shipper Squad
never win
I was going to ask you how frustrating
as a Clippers fan who's been
incarcerated during this kind of the
entire Kauai Paul George era because I
remember when they pulled that trade off
I was in Mexico
and that this is when Paul George got
traded uh to the uh from the Thunder to
the Clippers and then they got Kawhi I
just remember thinking to myself there's
nobody is gonna be able to beat these
[__] guys and it's just kind of been
whether it's injuries why'd you think
that
because in my head I'm not saying hey
trash why and Paul George are two of the
best perimeter defenders in the NBA
and then it's just there's so many super
teams these days to really even like
your squad ain't really nothing you got
to go against like it's [__] you
gotta go against the Suns there's crazy
ass scenes right now yeah some of them
didn't work out but for sure the net
[__] I don't know hey shout out to
everybody y'all [__] know what y'all
are doing y'all are doing all type of
weird and then you see shakers you can't
be you can't be doing let me let you uh
athletes know if you uh organizations
associations you can't be playing with
sports but people that are incarcerated
[__] listen
don't be stopping this [__] you feel me
don't be don't stop this [__] whatever's
going on
don't don't stop the game don't leave
the game
there's too many injuries now so it's
like free injuries it's the uh what they
call load management I've seen the [__]
brush against a [__] and be out for a
whole city man God damn it do you wish
you would have kept say guildress
Alexander in retrospect
see because SGA got shipped out to
Oklahoma certain people they gotta shine
at I think he would he's at his best
place right now that's fair now
everybody I like I like players like
that what about your football team who's
your football team
yeah
so out here you ain't gonna
around my age group you know I'm saying
we don't have a team but from here of
course because they were gone of course
so once we got a team I started going
for the Rams because in Texas
they take football is dead serious very
serious and I've seen a Louisiana dude
squabble with a Texas dude over the
Cowboys and the Saints really and I said
we doing all that so they'll fight in
jail over that well I seem to get Donkey
Kong punched into the trash can you know
he's flew in his car there he is
but my team my lifelong team is the
Packers they got the G's on their head
but
now we don't know quarterback what's
going on you got Jordan left
I said
we ain't got no [__] quarterback okay
give me your spread run down and like
what are you putting in the spray give
me the spread recipe
top tier best oh in jail I ain't no
spread that'd be for them [__] that
eat noodles and [__] we don't when you
get the money in jail noodles like for
the bombs on Craig did you guys yeah we
getting [__] from the kitchen like
somebody gonna fry some chicken or
something I was gonna say because I saw
some viral God my guard might leave a
box of pizza right here you might get a
box of pizza no I said I said hey no
skip past that let's see I was gonna say
I saw a viral video of somebody doing
like their version of Benihana's in in
the cell oh you did anything like that
some people be live on that Grill
they go They're gonna make a grill on
the bunk and [__] that'd be live on that
Grill you got to be careful with that
though
I don't know what the hell
uh yeah
he just like putting the lead paints
raised spray disinfectant on that [__]
yo it's crazy for hey I always hear
about how
um crazy
the LA County Jail is being in Texas
compared to being incarcerated out here
what's the differences if any or is it
is it like it's not the same game
politics then they gave a [__]
flip-flops in the county I was at you
know what I'm saying
um ain't no got them
and my enemies ain't out there so it's
regular you know man my enemies out here
so I ain't gotta worry about a lot more
stress-free I'm still catching like
squabbles here and there just on some
Mansion but were you like uh was it
pretty like
were you kind of a celebrity well while
being locked up in Texas no no maybe
like after like 2020 they were like oh
[__] and then I popped up it's a famous
magazine that we read in there called
kite it's like a magazine that [__] in
jail get to stay updated on music
and uh they saw me in there and that's
when they was like oh this [__] really
somebody else so
so you're gonna have a new music coming
uh with Uzi I was in some double XLS too
that once they start get catching word
yeah [__] double xl's [__] their
new freshman cover is very disappointing
to say the least I I said no it was a
lot of people no no there was definitely
some great people on there but there was
a few no Rob's dope but there was just a
few people that they left out that was
hard I [__] with too I think they
should have I ain't gonna lie 10 people
is really never gonna be enough it's
always gonna be there I just feel like
there's no West Coast representation
there's a kid in Texas nobody hot you
know look we gotta stop this [__] it's
some hot [__] now like you know but I
think somebody like Russell could have
been already and YG like the [__] that
stamped in but I'm saying we ain't gonna
if we don't upgrade the music out here
we are never like [__] we being
realistic [__] you know what the [__]
we did you know what wave this is like
well we've been nice let's let's be who
we really are you know German State
Mafia you know
what we did and what we helped the city
get up get off that chest
now there was other people that was
living like we was living they just
wasn't mainstream rappers at the time
and we the ones that did it
so it may be other people that was on
the same topics too but that's what we
we do it for like upgrade the music up
the way up upgrade the way you [__]
dress stop you know what I'm saying not
saying all you [__] be on it but like
[__]
I know I had created a certain Lane
and I saw some people kind of like
have a similar laner or even go with
what they learn from me whether they did
or not that's not what I'm saying but to
see so many people that went backwards
this is like damn what you think I did
it well I did that for all of us you
feel me there's a reason I get features
with [__] that the city don't usually
get them with there's a reason it might
be a [__] that everybody ain't even
heard of out here but I know the streets
is playing this you know what I'm saying
so
upgrade the music that's why we ain't on
that [__] what are you listening to
right now
um hot boy
rifle nine
uh ASM Bob
um just as far as like newer pictures
new [__] yeah what's in here like you
know I feel like people respect your
opinions all the females that come out I
don't care how it's being created people
like oh somebody's probably right now
whatever going on today going on I
always say putting that fire up under
these [__] ass [__] better start
saying something right now the females
are running circles around men when it
comes to making hit records [__] that
they slipping bars in there [__] that
[__] y'all [__] can't be I don't care
what genre of rap y'all trying to create
you gotta slip the bars in there you
know what I'm saying y'all be sleeping
on like [__] like Uzi and trippy and
[__] like that but them [__] really be
slipping bars in that [__] you know what
I'm saying you gotta lyrics matter so
you can bubble off just [__] for a
while but lyrics matter you gotta you
gotta be saying something don't blame
the system if I ever get lucky and get a
Grammy I am like you know y'all don't
show no love y'all finally show some
love let the Grammy be the Grammy you
feel me so you gotta let the first
recover it's still something that
it matters you know what I'm saying it
may not matter to people who feel like
they saw better but right this [__]
matters the people that got on that [__]
we can't discredit that [__] cause yeah
last year I mean we had early
representation I think it was the last
year blast was on there yeah this
level's blast bro so yeah 100 man well
listen you're uh I'm glad you're back
man I'm glad that uh you got new music
on the way
um
hopefully we hear some of these uh
these records that you're grinning
you're you're you're you're you're
you're you're I'm gonna call it your yes
grin throughout the interview when I'd
ask you something and you just hit me
with that I mean that grin
nah I mean [__] I'll be you know you
never know what's clear
and then sometimes when I say who I do a
song with they go leaky
what makes the music is it the engineers
is it somebody horny somebody was horny
about the [__] you know man somebody
geeked up they don't realize what it
does to the money you know what I'm
saying I'll give away free songs all day
but let's be on the same page don't
don't throw away the money songs
nah for sure don't leak the good [__]
for sure well I appreciate you pulling
up finally man I'm glad we got to find a
link brother for sure yes sir oh three
Greedo you already know boom hey
appreciate y'all watching another
interview brought to you by our good
Folks at hardean now listen y'all when
you're in Las Vegas you get in that
[__] Uber you land at the airport hit
that taxi tell him to take you to
hardine the number one premium cannabis
dispensary in the [__] world y'all
I'm telling you you walk in they treat
you like a king or a queen or whatever
you're into all right they got the
craziest selection to premium cannabis
you'll see period anywhere let alone in
Las Vegas but just anywhere all right
not only can you go get the best tree
you'll get the best experience the best
customer service the best bud tenders
you walk into hard Dean and that [__]
just smells amazing they got their own
[__] scent literally you get into my
car I got a bottle of it my car smells
like Harding because it's just the best
[__] place
um go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to their
website
hardinglasvegas.com all right when you
go you're in Vegas you pull up tell them
I sent you they're going to take care of
you the right way all right look they
got these things in there man these Moon
Rock uh pre-rolls that I just had that
just absolutely melted my face off
shout out to Heart Dean all right you
got to go [__] with hard Dean man
Harding underscore Las Vegas uh thank
y'all man I love these guys they're like
family to us and uh hey we're gonna drop
another interview soon if you're
watching this you're at the end of the
interview though much love